okay we've been covering Donald Trump
and immigration basically since before
he was even Republican nominee the
infamous they're not sending their best
they're sending criminals and rapists
and some I am sure are good people
comment and part of the absurdity of
Donald Trump's positions on undocumented
immigration are that he himself is a
perpetrator of the actual problem around
undocumented immigration which is that
companies hire undocumented immigrants
and don't suffer the consequences even
though strictly speaking it is against
the law it is very very easy for the
punishment to be levied only on the
undocumented immigrant via deportation
and not on the company doing the hiring
and I pointed out from the beginning
you're really going to deal with this
issue in a serious manner before you
even talk about a wall and what the wall
should be made of you have to start
holding accountable the companies that
are hiring undocumented immigrants we
now have a new revelation that not one
not two but three of Donald Trump's golf
clubs have fired undocumented immigrant
employees which they had been employing
in some cases for many many years this
latest news is about trump National Golf
Club Philadelphia which is in New Jersey
it's called trump National Golf Club
Philadelphia but it's not in
Philadelphia or even in Pennsylvania
it's in New Jersey this is the third
property to hire fire undocumented
workers we previously had a New York
Times report on employees at the
Bedminster New Jersey Club twelve
undocumented immigrants were fired there
since that report we've learned about
dozens of workers at trump National Golf
Club in Westchester in New York aware
dozens of employees undocumented
employees were fired and we now have
learned that at least five workers were
either fired or told never to come to
work again at Trump Golf Club
Philadelphia in New Jersey and there's
every expectation that there's going to
be many many more so the picture that is
very quickly being created accurately I
would I would add is the massive
hypocrisy of Donald Trump on this issue
we have not only the fact that while he
wants to build a wall and claims to be
tough on undocumented
raishin he has said nothing about going
after the companies doing the hiring of
undocumented immigrants but has himself
been a longtime employer of undocumented
immigrants not only at his clubs
but also even in construction projects
real estate construction projects that
he has done in New York City and in
other cities we learned that Donald
Trump's wife Melania worked illegally
here in the United States which Donald
Trump claims to want to deport people
for Melania Trump was initially here in
the US on a visa that did not allow her
to do any work and she did work which
goes against the visa that something
Donald Trump says he wants people
deported for doing and then of course
Donald Trump wants to get rid of all
sorts of paths to citizenship not only
birthright citizenship but also
something called chain migration and of
course Melania Trump's own parents have
become citizens via chain migration
which Donald Trump is against now the
defense here for Trump's persistent
employment of undocumented immigrants
has been will listen no one knew that
they were undocumented Trump definitely
didn't know even Trump's managers were
duped by these fake documents that the
employees presented and now we fired
everybody the problem of course is that
a report a couple of weeks ago exposed
that it was Donald Trump's businesses
that were providing the forged documents
to many of these employees so that's not
believable and we've only recently
gotten comment on this third Club that
was employing undocumented immigrants
from Eric Trump who simply called that
heartbreaking which is sort of weird
like what which aspect of it exactly is
it that's heartbreaking from Eric
Trump's point of view
consider the double standard consider
the double standard when you think back
to put aside for a second the no
consequences for the corporation's back
in 1993 President Bill Clinton nominated
zoe baird for attorney general it was
revealed that zoe Baird's husband had
once employed an undocumented immigrant
nanny and an undocumented immigrant
chauffeur okay Bill Clinton's age
nominees husband plea previously had
done that within eight days
Zoe Baird was forced into retracting her
nomination for attorney general donald
trump has employed dozens of
undocumented immigrants at multiple
businesses no consequences for the
company obviously no consequences for
trump and he still is touting himself as
the guy who's strong on undocumented
immigration people just shrug his
supporters don't care or they excuse it
things have changed radically from 1993
and they've changed radically even from
three years ago when President Obama was
president of the US